hello everyone so I'm actually going to
take you through a journey a journey
that I personally experienced with a
team that i have in Silicon Valley and
all over the world today Phoenix venture
capital we are a team of 53 venture
capitalists we are working together we
have people in 13 different locations
and we have branches in seven different
countries today we manage about close to
eight different forms anywhere ranging
from 220 to two hundred million dollars
so today I will actually talk about some
of the experiences that we had in the
last four to five years since the
establishment of this Phoenix venture
capital entity so first of all let me
introduce myself I'm honest Osmond and I
am actually the founding partner of
another venture capital I am an engineer
like yours many of you I'm sure that you
have a technical background as well so I
went to my did my bachelor degree in
electrical engineering from tokyo's
teacher of Technology and then I did my
master's degree back in Oklahoma State
so I was a Cowboy fan and then I i was
working in IBM i actually was doing
business development and many other
things in IBM margarine acquisition and
when i was doing my job i was also
working on my PhD with a professor in in
tokyo in tokyo metropolitan university
and in three years i actually are the
PhD degree from him i was most probably
the fastest chi PhD in history of japan
so i did most of my PhD work over skype
i made my professor over skype the only
thing i attended was the convocation I
guess so there's kind of quick brick
story I work in IBM and cadence today I
am the CEO feniks I actually kind of
help with the operations I also sit on
the board of a bunch of companies in in
Silicon Valley jet lore is a company
that came out of statics from Stanford
so I am a board director their dream
like entertain manage one of the public
companies in Japan I actually was an
investor
what did become they went through the IP
or last year so I am a board director
there I also sit on the board director
of lark which is also a Stanford company
from startex I'm helping them with their
operations I also set in the border of
tech in Asia key I undersea cruise and
recently I joined the board director of
info tarea which is they took your stock
exchange-listed company so how do I get
all this time so again as I'm working I
am also trying to help the entrepreneurs
around the world so as I i mainly invest
in Silicon Valley so most of my
investment if you look at sixty percent
of my investments are in Silicon Valley
and then you know I also invest in an
other geographies so when I started
looking into Asia I started investing in
Japan and when I hit japan I found that
there is not much knowledge about
entrepreneurship and innovation in that
country so I actually put together the
book based on some Q&A is that I had
with young entrepreneurs like yourself
and the book was called startup Bible
guess what the book was a great hit and
the book sold more than expected as the
book became very famous I actually got a
call from Korea and they said hey we
want the book to be published in Korea
so as of last year I published the book
in Korea and this is one of the pictures
you're seeing from my publication event
day in Korea along with me my Phoenix
Korea CEO Sean actually is also on the
cover page of the book the book became
so popular then I wanted to take the
book to some other regions where the
book can also give some benefit to the
young entrepreneurs like yourself so I
went to Indonesia and as of may last
month I actually publish the book ennis
in Indonesia as you see that as I go to
different region the book keeps changing
their its name why if you you cannot
sell startup Bible in Indonesia it is a
big religious problem they'll kill me so
we actually had to change the name to
start up area because there's more of an
acceptable name too because most of the
people are Muslims over there the book
actually had a huge huge huge hit
I actually got called by bloomberg
Indonesia again I was in Indonesia
morning show I got so popular I went to
a supermarket on the second day and some
random entrepreneur came to me and he
started talking to me in donation and
this keeps happening the whole day so I
said I better leave Indonesia before I
you know or maybe I stay back and go for
the election I didn't do that so I came
back I went back so this was in
Indonesia so let's talk about Phoenix a
little bit okay so phenix actually as i
mentioned we're at we have our branches
at seven different locations today
mainly headquartered in silicon valley
here in san jose but we have also people
around 13 different locations and we
have invested in many many companies we
have 53 different people at this point
so I'm going to the team a little bit
just to give you a few overview this is
our US team and as you can see the
people from different people different
areas we have a Japan team we have a
courier team we also have a team in in
Indonesia and Singapore and then we also
have a team in Bangladesh and in Dubai
we also have a team in Europe so this is
how our team is structured we are a
little bit big for a VC firm this
normally if you talk to a VC from they
have like 10 12 people at the maximum we
have 53 people and they're all working
for the same in a goal so where where
did you invest we invested in a bunch of
companies from across the globe at the
very upper left hand corner you see some
of our investments in Japan dl e
dribbling entertainment is our first
investment that went through an IPO last
year in March we also invested our
latest investment is met ups this is the
second largest fundraising in the
history of Japan and I'm very proud that
we are part of that on the United States
I'd one of our latest investments is
expect labs this is a company that came
out of MIT you might have heard of
shared these lark is a Stanford company
jet load is another Stanford company
these are some of the investments we
have done on the North American side in
the Southeast Asia side
was kind enough to tell about taking
Asia right taking Asia is the largest
it's the techcrunch of Asia is a little
bigger than that most probably at this
point we are actually proud investor up
taking Asia now we also invested in 16
different y combinator companies you'll
be surprised to know that my first
investment in North America was a
company called rap genius there was my
first investment when I invested into
that company I invested for evaluation
of 10 million dollar and today the
company is valued at a billion dollar
and that happened only in a span of two
years so that's the Y Combinator
experience I have gone through my first
investment ever had grown about 100 x
and and that gave us a punch line so we
keep investing into more and more y
combinator companies one of the
companies that I'm very proud of is
called meta em ETA it's a combination of
artificial intelligence and virtual
reality you definitely want to have a
look at the cool videos they have on
YouTube you also want to definitely have
a look at a company called ed YN they
actually are doing the IOT for
agricultural devices there's a very
interesting component to have a look at
so let's talk about the real topic
that's what I came here for that how you
can create or how as a VC we can help
the ecosystem to actually hook people
things up so I will actually rely on a
few examples so before I do that yha is
important right that's we need to know
that and I'm sure that you already know
a lot about it but I'm going to show you
a video just excite yourself a little
bit more
you
so H is rising and everybody understand
that and I personally have realized that
as the CEO of Phoenix that I not only
want to be in the core space which is
Silicon Valley where you can actually
really make a fortune out of this
venture capital business but I also
thought that I do not want to miss the
opportunities in Asia that's why I have
always always always as the CEO has have
looked for the best of the best
opportunities and I have recently you'd
be surprised to know that I've opened at
200 million dollar fund for far away in
the East in Bangladesh recently so I've
done that much because I do not want to
be able to tell my kids that oh I miss
that I want to be tell that when there
was a big wave I was part of that that's
what I want to be double able to tell
and I want to take you through that that
wow I have thought through the whole
process let's look at the population
when I'm thinking about business that I
want to expand my business there are a
few things that i'm looking at i'm
always always looking at the population
demographics is the most important thing
as a businessman the second thing that
you're looking at is the internet
penetration rate and the mobile
penetration rate if you look at the
world population sixty-seven percent of
the world population are living in asia
right you cannot ignore that the second
biggest criteria that you want to see is
the number of Internet users of the
world if you look at the number of
Internet users about 1.3 billion United
internet users are living in Asia only
you cannot ignore that fact forty-five
percent of these people are living in in
Asia and if you look at more precisely
into this table that I've shown i'm
showing here only thirty-four percent of
the asian population are using internet
today now let's look at another
viewpoint this is some there's some
article here as you can see that South
Asia is fastest growing region in the
world by South Asia we are talking about
in your countries like India countries
like Pakistan Bangladesh and and those
region asian countries actually have
grown almost three hundred percent the
gdp has grown 300
and between the year 2001 and 2013 so
this is the growth rate portfolio of
these Asian countries and that's why
Asia is very important i'm going to show
you another video which will give you
some stat did you know more than half of
the world's population lives in the
circle surprisingly it's around 4
billion people who live in Asia imagine
that more and more of them are connected
through the internet and enjoy online
shopping traveling abroad on vacation
with friends and family to the 90s Asia
was home of industrial production for
decades supplying goods as the world's
manufacturing plant led to amazing
results money flowed into Asia through
exports and it helped drive the economic
development and urbanization of the
region all the while Asians became more
educated and more skilled as a workforce
with better paying and more innovative
jobs than before finally they have
transformed themselves into powerful
consumers this rising tide of Asian
consumption is shifting world dynamics
Alibaba online market has emerged in
China that is larger than Amazon and
eBay combined furthermore mikal's casino
industry is now six times larger than
Las Vegas
six of 10 diabetic patients in the world
reside in Asia who will require more
medical care and medicine in the future
Asia is the continent of economic
miracle with a large well-educated
urbanized population who enjoy economic
and income growth to power their rising
consumer purchases Asia is a
fast-changing region that has come very
far and has a promising future ahead so
with this rising wave of Asia I mean we
have thin large corporations are going
to asia from walmart to Pfizer to anyone
you can think of from mcdonalds to
caterpillar everyone is going to Asia to
find out the biggest opportunities there
that is happening in the region but we
cannot ignore this trollops startups if
you look at all the steps you will find
that most of the startups are preferring
to go to Asia over Europe because of the
large number of consumers we have there
we cannot ignore that and I will
actually explain you a few of the things
that I have experienced personally so
these are some of the you know articles
that i have brought up which shows that
you know everybody is focusing more and
more towards AJ when they start ups are
actually doing the same and also as you
can see some of the very famous startups
like uber Airbnb Dropbox snapchat they
are all all moving to asia and they're
preferring asia over any other countries
outside of united states so let's find
out how these stirrups are actually
going and what is what is the benefit
they are looking out of this first of
all as you're going to Asia as you're
seeing to third of the world population
are living there that means that two
third of the world consumers are living
in Asia so first of all you're seeing a
bigger addressable market so you can
actually sell your product more you can
make more revenue cheaper labor is
another thing you cannot ignore the
cheaper labor you'd be surprised that
most probably Phoenix my company is
growing faster in Indonesia than in
Silicon Valley because I can find an
employee in Indonesia at a lot cheaper
rate than i can find over here obviously
there might be a little bit of
difference in terms of like the
knowledge level and and and then the
depth of knowledge but obviously i can
actually i have to compare the cost
versus the quality and still I feel that
Indonesia is a great market for our of
her ass to expand diverse partnership
opportunities I mean even in if you go
to Indonesia or Bangladesh or India or
Thailand I mean there are big players
there you can actually you'll be
surprised to know that phenix we
actually partnered with one of the
largest telecommunication company in
Indonesia called telecom telkom is most
probably one of them they have the
largest number of consumers in whole
Asia by the way talking about Indonesia
you might be wondering why I'm talking
about Indonesia Indonesia is the
fourth-largest populated country in the
whole planet today so China India China
India United States and the
fourth-largest populated country is
Indonesia you'll be also surprised to
know that next year in 2016 Indonesia is
going to have 100 million Internet users
you cannot ignore that internet on the
hands of 100 million people I mean you
need to address that market and we are
one of the very early people going into
that country and trying to get hold of
the whole business over there so now the
challenges of expanding into this
country's I mean I'm sure that we have
people here who are related to startups
with people here who are in large
corporations and there are a lot of
challenges and first of all is
competition I mean the local competition
can be fierce and the only way you can
overcome the local competition is
through partnership with with your
competitor communication barrier is
something that you cannot ignore the all
different Asian countries that is
speaking different languages branding
has to be different it has to be
localized that's why globalization and
localization has to play a role together
and then obviously have cultural gap
regulation gap and obviously as you're
going to a new country I mean obviously
you have to have supporters here most
probably in this country who are ready
to fund you to actually go and expanding
to this degree in into the into a new
region so these are some of the
challenges that you face now how you can
overcome this most probably the
only answer I have for you is through
partnership and I'm going to show you
some of the partnerships that we have
offered to some of the companies and how
they have gone through from one step to
another and have globalized themselves
so first of all I will talk about and
I'll give you an example where we have
helped bridge the gap of Asia to us we
have helped one of the Asian partners to
actually have a flavor of us and as if
he see we actually worked as the partner
that you bridge that gap so I'm going to
talk about taking Asia so taking Asia is
the largest technology media company now
in Asia and you'll hear about them all
over the place if you want to know about
what is happening in Asia I will
recommend you to read start reading take
in Asia calm every day I do it because I
want to be connected I want to know what
is happening over there so this is the
CEO his Willis way he is from Singapore
this company is headquartered in
Singapore but they actually operate
mainly today from Indonesia they're the
techcrunch of Asia in some sense today
they had a team of 54 people they are
writing about 150 articles a a month
with with 14 interviews per month and
obviously they have a total number of
unique page views of 5.5 9 million so
this is what the stats look like they
are actually located across 11 different
countries within a within Asia and if
you look at their growth rate in the
last one and a half year they have grown
four hundred percent and and that is
that shows you how fast these regions
are growing today so from 550 k at the
end of 2013 to where we took the stat in
in april of 2015 it was 2.2 million
pageviews unique visitors so they also
do three different conferences across
Asia they actually do the first
conference in Singapore which is done in
May time frame then then do the second
conference in start-up asia in in Tokyo
they do it in the sep tember time frame
and then they do the final one in
Jakarta Indonesia and they do this
conference in November time frame and
these three conferences are the largest
conferences we just finished one in
Singapore there are 3,000 people
entrepreneurs investors large
corporations they participated in this
event because they want to be part of
this big revolution that is happening in
Asia so what happens now we find this
company when we were about to go to
Southeast Asia and wanted to find out
what is the best company to invest in we
also wanted to have a strategic partner
who can actually help us in other areas
so we decided that we want to be that us
partner or silicon valley partner of
tech in Asia so we actually ended up
investing into this company tech in Asia
and since then we have invested about
four times within the latest round with
some other players after we invested as
a I actually joined the board and one of
my colleague also from Phoenix he also
joined the board he's also from
Singapore and he actually by the way is
a professor in Stanford as well so we
both joined the board of tech in Asia
and the first thing that we wanted to do
we wanted to give it a kick so what we
do it as a board director we actually
tore taking ages CEO that most probably
he should prevail your number one
position when you took over the company
or took over extra bored bored we found
that taking issue is still number one in
terms of technology media companies in
Asia but at the same time they're very
close to their second competitor and the
third and the fourth they're very close
to each other so what we did is we told
less use some of our investment money
towards buying out some of this
competitor let's buy out so what we did
we actually ended up purchasing the
third largest player of technology media
called is she entrepreneur it's a
Singaporean technology media company and
that gave it a pretty solid number one
position that is the first thing we did
as a board director as an advisor to the
company so also we did that then we also
wanted to make sure it was a very much
southeast asian company it was in
Singapore ters in Thailand it was in
Vietnam Philippines but it was not in
Tokyo it was not in Korea it was not in
you know on the eastern part of Asia so
we wanted to give it a kick so if we
actually suggested
them let's do the next startup Asia
event in Tokyo let's do that so we
brought in the first startup Asia event
in tokyo on sep tember of 2014 i am the
one who actually had to call all the
keynote speakers to actually get their
commitment that we are going to do this
event in Tokyo and and it was one of the
biggest event they have done in their
history and we have to pull it off so I
basically had to propose them all
different types of panels to all key
North I personally did a keen or myself
and I also called in some very famous
people lined up as the speakers of this
conference and guess what we made it
happen and you'll be surprised the the
number of people attended this event was
most probably the highest in the history
of Japan and this happened last year and
they're going to do it in Tokyo second
time again in September of this year so
that's what we did that's how we bridge
the gap between Singapore to Tokyo now
we wanted to give it some more cake we
wanted to make it a global company and
that's what good investors too I think
being in Silicon Valley you know the
concept of the smart money and dumb
money right so when as an investor we
actually give money plus advice that's
called smart money and most of the
Silicon Valley investors are good at
giving a smart money and that's what we
wanted to do to with our some of our
investment so this is our second cake so
what we did we always always try to
promote networking parties this is
actually a dinner party I know that mr.
Cutler is here from dial securities so
he was also in the party his picture is
here sorry so we did a party in april of
2014 in tokyo and we arranged the party
phoenix and first time what i did I
actually invited two partners from y
combinator to come to Tokyo and this is
the first time in the history of Y
Combinator they were in Tokyo and I am
the one who invited them I actually
arranged a dinner and first time I
actually put taking Asia CEO and Y
Combinator together so that they can
meet I had a goal my goal was to
take in Asia that Asian English media
but also be having a good positioning in
Y Combinator coming to this country
through some good channels through some
good bridges and that bridge was Y
Combinator this was the first meeting
that they had and you see this picture
this was liked a lot of times a lot of
people actually liked this picture and
then guess what this year in March 2015
they were accepted as one of the
companies they're the first company we
most probably with the series be status
who actually came from Singapore to
Tokyo to Silicon Valley and became a
global company now when you come to Y
Combinator and get qualified as a y
combinator company what happens you get
funding because people want to give you
money because people know you not guess
what they got money from many different
players they got money from softbank
they got money from Walden international
they got money from Phoenix again and
they became a global entity that's what
most prob later today shall you
requested me to talk about right that
how these investors can grow a company
slowly one step at a time but you can
become a global entity today they got a
lot of funding they are exposed and they
are most probably going to establish
themselves as one of the largest Asian
English technology media company so I'm
going to sofa docks played a major role
and I'm not going to talk about phenix
here I'm going to talk about how the
bridging can happen I'm just giving you
an idea as you'll be working in a large
corporation or even building up your own
startup or do something this is how most
probably you can find a partner who can
help you with the bridging I'm going to
talk about another story I'm going to
talk about a story and where the CEO is
from Stanford and where we actually
helped an us company bring the bringing
to Asia this is a company called lark
most probably you might actually do a
search and find out lark is the first
variable in the planet so before people
actually had
the world wearable lark was the first
wearable there is no confusion in my
mind and I was one of the early investor
in to this company this company actually
is from startex which is an organization
within Stanford and and I'm very proud
that this company still is doing
extremely good so let me talk about the
CEO Julia who is a chinese-american CEO
I think I think she was born in this
country her parents are from China she
became the women entrepreneur of the
year in 2011 by mary claire magazine she
also became top 30 human under 30 by I
NC she became so popular that even
President Barack Obama called her in the
Christmas party and asked for a lark
device and she said he have to buy and
that's why President Obama is saying
that why I have to buy I'm the president
I should get one for free right so she's
told nobody gets it for free when the
president so I think so this is a
picture from there and this is Julia who
you can see her she's looking very you
know all makeup and stuff but this is
just for a magazine picture she's a very
simple person in general so teman
advisors what made lot very unique and I
will talk about so they came up with the
hardware and software i'll show it in a
minute but this company actually became
very popular because of the background
of its CEO and the employees and the
advisors they had on board they had most
of the employees and advisors and board
directors came from Stanford Harvard and
MIT Julia herself graduated from
Stanford and completed her postgraduate
studies in MIT and Harvard and she not
only had all of the advisors coming from
these three schools she also had a lot
of Olympic coaches coaching her so I
invested in this company in in 2012 and
I'll show you some of the devices that
they actually started building at that
time so lark life was the device it was
sold in app store in any apple store
actually and they had both hardware and
software and there is no other device at
that point so let's look at this story I
mean it was a nice blue
device that you could put on your hand
and you had a nap in your application in
your cell phone and then you could
actually see how many how much you're
sleeping at night and you know how many
steps you're walking and things like
that I'm talking about 2011-12 timeframe
when larks silent alarm clock really
really an sleep monitoring system really
became a big hit a tell-all Apple stores
and you know it was a software and
hardware combination and it was doing
fantastic this is the device and then
Phoenix invests and you can see some of
the presses that actually shows that
Phoenix became an investor into this
company we are brought in by some other
players a player called asset management
the partner his name is escape Fleshman
he's also Stanford Graduate he actually
invited me to join actually this company
and join the board ultimately so I'm
still sitting at the board of this
company and trying to grow this company
so after I became joined the board and
we invested in this company we actually
wanted to give it a shot so actually
brought it to Japan and you are seeing a
flyer of lard product this is the night
band as you can see so this is the
product they started selling to some of
the Japanese retail stores and we
actually helped you know promote that
into the Japanese market now guess what
competition this is something that I
want you to learn from they were growing
slowly and the speed was not fast enough
most probably and there are like big big
competition that came out job on Fitbit
well nike they all came out at the same
time frame it was very very difficult
for lark to actually compete with these
big players so guess what not only that
we also ran into some other problem I
mean I talked to dr. Dasher earlier
before present before when I was
proposed for this panel and we're
talking about that most of the companies
in in us their most probably
manufacturing in China so lark was doing
the same and I was I could not agree
with him more that yes I mean most of
the hardware companies in Silicon Valley
are also manufacturing most of the stuff
in China so these people were larkhall
so what men
actually this device in in Eagle factory
in China inch engine which is close to
Hong Kong and guess what the yield was
so bad only 29 twenty five percent yield
so every hundred device there are 75
devices which were wrong which is faulty
which could not could not use and they
were not ready the contract they put the
contract in such a way they were not
taking any blame for it just you paid
you got 25 good devices so good luck
basically so we could not handle this
anymore I mean it was so cash incentive
intensive I mean we had we had to
scratch our head again and again and see
like what is it that you can do and we
already was seeing some losses in in
China so we decided that you should pull
out of china so we went to China we had
some good time partying of maybe they
changed our manufacturing line and then
we went down to twenty five percent
yield and then we had to pull out so we
had to pull out and guess what we
actually moved the whole manufacturing
to us and our yield was ninety-eight
percent man what do they eat versus what
do we eat here so that was a big
difference but at the same time I was
mentioning you we are facing another
challenge that feed bit was there nike
was their job one was that they're
killing us right i mean they're all over
the place so we had to change some
strategy so we did a big pivot i told
you that we are working with a lot of
advisers from Stanford MIT and harvard
medical schools and also we had a lot of
advisors who are Olympic coaches so what
we did we actually pivoted our software
and we actually converted from hardware
software operation to a fully software
operation company where we started
converting all the data collected by all
these wearable devices that you see
today in the market take their data and
convert that data into advice it is a
combination of science and arts now tell
you if you're wearing a jawbone device
or a nike device it tells you how many
steps you have walked today it tells you
that you know how much
you ran today but it does not tell you
what does that mean to you it does not
coach you anything right so what luck
does it will take the data most probably
job one has given you that this is how
many steps you work today it tells you
that you should sleep today half an hour
earlier then you will have a nice sound
sleep that is arts my friend that's not
science so what they have done they have
talked with all these experts and they
have tried to put together science and
arts together and created a database
that can coach you to have a better life
they have different programs for good
sleeping diet relaxation stress
reduction and many others and that's how
they have prevailed today if you look at
lark actually devoted and became a fully
software based company and they have
done very well not only that what we did
we also brought in well he died in our
board well he died he is I think the
97th most powerful woman in in the world
right now she actually also is the
founding president of marvell
semiconductor which is one of the
largest semiconductor company in Silicon
Valley they look at in San Jose area so
she actually joined the board she joined
the board with a lot of lot of power and
resources so it was great working with
heart she still actually sits on the
board with me today so will he die
actually as she brought in she brought
in her China connection because she was
very big in China she actually the
graduate graduate and PhD from Berkeley
University so with the new team we
actually launched the software and and
within all the Samsung platform you'll
be surprised to know that samsung galaxy
s5 had every single of their phone
pre-installed with lark not only that if
you look at lark it not only attracted
great partners actually if you look at
iphone all the latest m8 lar kept became
the apple health kit default application
of as well so both Samsung with the
Android side and the iOS
they cover both and they're one of the
most favored you know application you
see today when it comes to you know
maintains your health and health
coaching so we actually did a lot of
work bringing them from just being a
Silicon Valley company to a global
entity where the latest round that a
fundraising that we are doing we are
involving a lot of players from China
with involving a lot of players from
Indonesia a lot of lives from Japan and
we're trying to make it from a Silicon
Valley only company to a global company
and that's how most probably if he can
also become a partner or the bridge
provider which can actually bridge the
u.s. components to the Asian countries
I'll talk to you about another company
is Asia to Asia so you might be
wondering how a Silicon Valley vc can
become a aj to a bridge player and i'll
give you a good example so I also
personally invested and I'm very proud
of investing in a company called Terra
motors so this is actually most probably
if you call a Tesla of Asia I think it
is Terra motors I have no confusion
about that so this person actually his
name is Toru takushi gay he is the CEO
of the company and he looks more like
Vietnam yesterday but his Japanese
originally so because he lived in South
decision for too long time so this is a
company that actually does electric
bikes and scooters so they are a good
assembly line they also made some of
their own product like little parts
which actually comes and makes this
quarter and an electronic bikes so they
actually definitely compare themselves
to Tesla here in the US I'm going to
show you some of the products here so
you see that try cycle they call it took
took in in Thailand so remember took
took and that they call it in Thailand
so they came up with the most the
best-looking took took that he'd have
ever seen and they're very proud I mean
whenever you talk to him he said that
the only thing that I'm proud of proud
about Taylor motors it is Ned in Japan
and he's selling the brand and he was
using it and he is making good out
feed you know he's seeing a lot of
traction out of this so not only that he
wanted to be modern you know it's there
like a scooter or a motorcycle I mean
how can you be modern so you can
actually patch this iphone on this on
the dock of this of the sea scooter and
you can tell you that how much better is
left how many miles you it will run and
when you need to charge it again and how
is it good how your scooter is doing
overall so it talks about the health
through the iphone amazing these guys
are doing great so I'll tell you one
interesting thing that when this person
mr. Thoreau takushi gay was trying to
become global he was desperately looking
for a partner to work with he was
desperate to find out a partner he when
I met him and and I told him that I'm
interested he said that my dream came
true I was looking for you I was looking
for a Silicon Valley best player who can
actually take me and give me the biggest
exposure because Japan as you know it's
an island it's a isolated country it is
not connected to Southeast Asia it is
not connected to us directly I mean it's
just an island so he was having a
trouble exposing his product which was
sweet table for the Southeast Asian
market so what we did we took it and as
you can see this is a a press release at
privateequity.com so we became a player
in the ten-million-dollar round that
they had at that point and we become an
investor and we invested financially and
then what we did we introduce them to
another player another of our family
member taking Asia we told them Terra
Motors is the company that you should
work with because Terra motors needs a
good exposure to the asian market tech
in Asia was more than happy it is not
because we are investor in taking issue
do not want to buy us there you know
news articles but we told them it's a
good enough company to be in news in
your newspaper they did many many
stories of Terra motors it not only
helped take in Asia grow their
viewership and their technology lead but
it helped terra motors big-time all this
happen
and I will show you the articles Terra
motors starts getting media attention
they got contract from all over the
place in Vietnam they got contract in
Philippines and they were looking for
next so guess what they were looking for
their next connection in Bangladesh
Bangladesh is a tough country it's a
developing country you understand it's
the third world country and you need
connections to get in so luckily one of
our general partners of Phoenix is
sitting in Bangladesh and he is the
chairman of basis which is the
Bangladesh Software Association through
him we actually helped terra motors to
actually expand their market in
Bangladesh we have gone all the way to
help him to actually make him a winner
all over the country and he just needed
he was already a very intelligent kid he
just needed a little push from the
people who he was trusting right so we
just pushed him a little bit towards the
forward and he actually will be able to
make it out so Taylor motors is a story
where we actually took a Japanese
company and held them in Vietnam in
Philippines and you helped them all the
way up to Bangladesh now let me tell you
that what we are doing as a company to
build our ecosystem how we are building
that ecosystem so that we can help our
portfolio companies because our
portfolio companies are our kids I mean
these are our sons and daughters and we
have to grow them and make them the most
successful companies in the planet so
we're all as always thinking how we can
build this infrastructure as feniks so
that we can help our portfolio companies
so first thing so we actually when we
started expanding into Asia we actually
looked into that how can have a big
media partner who can help our portfolio
companies how we can work with the
government how the we can work with the
largest incubators how we can work with
the largest mobile operators and how we
can work with the academia with the top
universities and schools locally where
you can get good deal sources deal
source we can do deal good deal sourcing
and at the same time hook up our
portfolio components so that they can do
better
so we have taken a lot of steps we have
gone to Singapore and we became a
partner of the largest incubator in
Singapore called jfgi this is most
probably the largest incubator in whole
of Southeast Asia and Phoenix is one of
the only investor from North America
into this company why we did this we did
this because we wanted to help our
portfolio companies today if you go to
Singapore and you need a friend I will
be able to write an email to the jfgi
CEO and he will host you there there's
the power we have and jfgi being the
largest incubator they are well
connected to all the government to all
the large corporations over there so as
a family member you get to leverage
their connections as well second thing
we did we also work with some of the
organizations who are already in Asia
for example founder institute founder
institute as you know they have branches
all over the world this is one of
another American organizations which
have done really good globally we have
partnered with them for example in
Bangladesh we partnered with them and we
are offering prizes or awards to some of
the top startups that are coming out of
Bangladesh think about it today we see
amazon ebay in the u.s. I mean we have
seen that in Japan we have seen Ali Baba
in China you will see the same Alibaba
in all the top populated countries we
have already seen a company called
tokopedia which got 100 million dollar
from softbank and it is the ebay of
indonesia you will see the same thing in
bangladesh do you know that bangladesh
is the eighth-largest populated country
in the world and it has number of
Internet users the number of Internet
users is bigger than the population of
canada so that's what you have to look
at and that's what where the opportunity
is and we are trying to get that
opportunity tech in Asia is another
partner that we are helping us in asia
and they're also becoming a global
entity that are helping a lot of our
portfolio companies getting exposure in
all over the world we're also doing
we're also doing
networking part is to put everyone
together we are actually doing three
networking parties in a year in Asia one
time in Singapore ons in Tokyo and once
in Indonesia if you want to become part
of this networking party please
definitely you're more than welcome to
become part of it we are doing the next
party in Tokyo in September so let me
tell you about the Tokyo part-ii OMG
what you are doing we always know that
Japanese large corporation in Tokyo they
have a tough time meeting the top
startups so we have invited 200 top
executives in Tokyo large corporate
executives and we have invited 50 global
top CEOs to do a networking party in
September 9th this year so that's what
we are doing we are getting our
portfolio companies and that companies
which have a top potential in Asia and
putting them with the top CEOs in Tokyo
penick's as a global player is able to
do that you'll be surprised to know that
calling in 200 CEOs at the same party is
not something that can be done very
easily and we have been doing that we
have been we have done that last month
in Singapore will we do that in Tokyo
and we'll do that in Jakarta and that's
how we are doing the bridging so that
this companies can be successful so
these are some of the companies that
have participated in our networking part
is so far and it is going to grow from
now and as you can see if there's a lot
of Japanese players a lot of singaporean
and an indonesian players actually
becoming part of this and then I will
end my presentation by saying that you
know us is a comfortable market this is
the market that you have started you
have started your business but this is
not the last market this is a great
market to start with us still can be
proud of the having the highest GDP in
the world but things are growing things
are changing and being you being in the
top educational institution in the whole
world I think you deserved something
bigger not only us plus alpha you need
to also be winner at the Asian market
and I feel the same way that's why I
suggest that we all become very global
and it is also crucial to find the right
partner to work with I'm sure that many
of you will build a start-up if you
build a start-up and if your big dream
you need to know you know what to do now
contact me and get money from me so that
I can help you to go global and and and
and go global really in the real sense
we can all actually help each other and
build the bridges so that we can help
not only large corporations but also set
ups as phenix we have also worked with a
lot of large corporations you'll be
surprised to know that we have eight
different funds than we are almost
managing about 1.5 billion dollar right
now ninety-eight percent of our
investors are large corporations and
these corporations are from Europe and
Japan and in Asia so we have been also
working with large corporations and
helping these large corporations to get
a flavor of the top startups around the
world so that we are building we are
also bridging the gap between large
corporations and in startups putting
them together so that they can they can
be winner the large corporations can
accelerate their innovation through the
help of startups and is set up at the
same time can get some acquisition
opportunity and partnership opportunity
through the friendship with large
corporations that's what we're doing
thank you very much I get to ask the
first question how did you get into this
how did you see this vision was this
something that you wanted you knew you
wanted to do from the very first time
you got into doing venture capital very
good question and I will actually so you
know the concept of Lean Startup right
listen to your consumers and I did the
same so when I started phenix venture
capital I actually got heavily invested
by an European investor and they were
ready to the made a commitment to invest
up to a billion dollar into my venture
capital firm because I had previous
track record with them they believed me
as I started venture capital and started
investing mainly in Silicon Valley I got
approached by a lot of Asian large
corporations and this asian large
corporations what they wanted
they wanted innovation to be part of
their business L also the large
corporations realized that they cannot
do R&D the traditional R&D and be
innovative and fight in the world level
they knew that they need to cooperate
collaborate with top startups around the
world to actually become the winner and
to be on the age of technology and be
like the frontrunners so they contacted
me and they told me that we want to
invest in Phoenix in return we want you
to show what you see so that became a
very unique model and I learnt it from
the large corporations who pushed me to
create this model so one after another
today in the last two to three years we
have welcomed 10 large Japanese
corporations to become our investor and
in return we are showing them about
8,000 startups in a year that's what we
see as Phoenix and we will need one
clarification when you say large
corporations yeah a lot of venture
capital is invested by financial
institutions are these financial
institutions or they other kinds of
large corporations these are other type
of large corporations these are
corporations like IBM these are
corporations like Sony these are
corporations like you know General
Electric so these are corporation which
actually have product they're B to C or
B to B type of corporation they are not
financial institutions so this the huge
change we saw and because of this heavy
push from the large corporation side
phenix most probably became the first VC
where ninety-eight percent of our
investors become large corporations
great let me open the floor go ahead you
first okay what is the origin and
meaning of words and obsolete means
nothing it is just a good name so I
actually inherited this so my first
investor was a corporation in Europe and
I inherited the name from them and later
on we got pushed so much by different
corporations from around the world that
we had to grow our fund from the first
one to eight different funds today
and you know this is just because the
consumer needed it I just followed the
Lean Startup model in this case but
Phoenix meant nothing I inherited the
name and I got the copyright now to
actually use the name for my company yes
your honor I'll see you very active in
Japan Sox tasia and now English you kind
of mentioned China in passing um but I'm
just curious you know what's been your
approach china so far why isn't it not
why isn't it not kind of featuring as
prominently as all dimensions so so let
me give you the honest answer and then I
will give you the executive answer okay
i'll give you both so we have to do
business so i am as a fair knocks I'm
also seeing that I have to look at my
competition and I also need to find out
how I can beat the competition so I'm
giving you the informal answer the
informal answer is when i looked at
china and india i saw all the big
players are all gathered there and
they're trying to figure out how they're
going to win when I looked at Indonesia
there was no one and I thought that this
is the fourth largest populated country
in the planet and it's the blue ocean
I'm going to take it over that was good
enough for me you see my point that is
the casual answer you're not you're
recording it oh my god so I have given
the glow but the you know the formal
answer would be of China is another
country most probably were looking at
we're working through partners how about
that you have a team in Europe and
expanding you want to be global I
represent sea and the Silicon Valley
board and so we a year looking Yahweh
lauder Nordic and / Baltic companies a
lot of entrepreneurship have you looked
any interest in that part of the world
as well yes we have looked at a lot of
companies from eastern europe russia
belarus ukraine I personally went to
Ukraine a few times and we have kept
looking we also look a lot of companies
from Israel I mean which is a CI europe
i do not know how do you call it in
between so we have looked at a lot of
companies and we have ended up investing
in a quite a few of companies which are
European
in origin for example we invested in a
company called 3x or seniors from UK
right started by some Eastern European
kid so we have done a lot but most cases
we have picked up the companies who have
agreed to actually come to Silicon
Valley and open up their branches hair
and go global because we're also looking
at the number of consumers that you have
right so if they're not willing to come
outside of their own country so I have
had a company approached me from Belarus
and they said I have ninety percent of
the Belarusian market in the e-commerce
space and I still did not want to invest
because ninety percent of Belarusian
market is most probably one less than
one percent of the North American market
so that's what it is in Finland for
instance and in Sweden a lot of gaming
companies and we know that in Asia
there's a lot of interesting games I
could see interesting synergies between
you know what the Nordic companies could
provide in terms of great gaming
technology and so on and finding markets
in Asia so connecting the Nordics with
Asia I think yeah that's what I'm
interested in that is the best benefit i
can get out of dr dashers the good when
we thought Mauro for ya get my business
card up to this and this is time to
start hooking up nordic to asia talking
back so i decided a couple questions
before me what did you and you have you
invested in other wearable companies and
probably you wanted to spray into a
certain category we're on a spring in a
certain category we have been more than
specific in a certain categories so we
have also invested in a bunch of other
variables like we have invested in a
company called meta which is the you
know kind of google glass but with
artificial intelligence and virtual
reality on the top of that we have
invested in a company called Bella beat
which actually helps with the pregnant
women listen to their babies right so we
have invested in the bunch of other we
have been visited in a company called
GTR which actually helps you play the
guitar and learn guitar with your iPhone
patched into it so yes we have invested
into a bunch of companies which are
variables
and at the same time you know we do not
believe in like investing again and
again in the same domain right but we
have almost looked into the special
qualities into this company's something
that they actually did that actually got
our attention we have actually invested
into those companies outside angel ng
see right you CA see em series we
actually have different strategies for
different regions I will break that down
so for North America we do seed and
series a we also do follow on series be
for our existing portfolio for Asia for
Japan we actually do a lot of tree IPOs
likes is B and C we started doing some
serious right now in Southeast Asia we
have started doing a lot of series b
because of the valuation of the
company's its recently because series
bees are getting hard to get in we
started doing some students it is a in
bangladesh it's mostly series a we do
not talk seed so it varies depending on
the region and valuations of startups
interval in those regions can I follow
up on that how big is a series a round
and Bangladesh good question so we just
completed a an investment into a company
called show host calm which is the kayak
of Bangladesh kayak exactly same thing
they're selling tickets and in any
country you go there is a kayak com by
the way and all of them are successful
even in Indonesia so we did investment
in Charles calm it was valued at series
a it was valid at eight million post and
you know we invested I think 1.5 million
dollar something like that yes so that's
not I I guess maybe here in Silicon
Valley series I valuation would be 15 or
20 and you would invest about five or
six exactly yes but it's still not that
much different not that much different
but it was a little bit this company
quality was a little better because the
CEO actually is a Harvard in the a and
she went back to Bangladesh and did this
by the way most of these startups in
Bangladesh and Indonesia are run by
entrepreneurs who actually graduated
either from Stanford Harvard or Connie
you know like in the surprise
ninety-nine percent so that companies
that I have invested in Bangladesh two
companies we invested in yahoo or
Bangladesh which has the largest traffic
in Bangladesh I got a good deal on that
for two hundred thousand dollars i got
fifteen percent in seed round seat plus
and this guy actually graduated from UT
Austin he has and he's definitely a
killer the second person I told you I
got a series a 48 million and it was a
little expensive because the see you had
a Harvard MBA and I could not say
anything me they say lady I mean I could
not negotiate much wanted to be a
gentleman and so it's kind of like that
even in Indonesia go most of the
entrepreneurs that you're interesting
they're all US graduates so there's one
of the communal Casey m1 you only trying
to be very comfortable playing with
servici both both so if in Asia Asia I
want to take the lead as much as
possible in u.s. i also want to grow
with other players i also want to make
sure that there are other players who
can help them on the US side also so
mainly work with other large feces so in
u.s. itself we have invested with more
than a 100 pcs right now 100 plus
species and most of the most cases yes
we have syndicated because the u.s.
rounds are also pretty big and in the
seed series around we tend to see the
entrepreneurs want to have multiple
pieces rather than one pc so they
definitely want to have panels because
they have this you know future plan of
expanding into asia so they definitely
want to have Phoenix in the portfolio
but they say that you know at the CD is
there maybe you guys put only twenty
percent money not more than that in
series b why don't you take like 30 or
40 percent and expand into Asia so
that's how we are seeing more and more
so you mentioned like for example
Bangladeshi but and 19 million dollars
so what are sort of the potential pan
out of companies in Asian like in the US
the Holy girls either IPO or a large
acquisition so like what would be the
future in Asia so i'll give you one real
example and he will
have an idea so there's a company called
i mentioned tokopedia which is the
largest which is kind of like eBay of
Indonesia so tokopedia investors the
early investors invested in a valuation
of likes a three-million-dollar or four
million dollar so the seed LCD the
investor so they just completed their
series see they got invested by softbank
I will say that the valuation will be
close to 300 plus million dollar at this
point and they actually bought out all
the shares of c density the investors
yeah so it's a wash basin you can see
that it was the large players want to
have a business relationship so I'm sure
that as you're growing your company
because these companies are so similar I
was talking about Charles calm which is
the kayak of Bangladesh I can just talk
to the kayak see you almost probably if
the market is big enough you will pick
it up so it's easy that way and also
like you'd be surprised to know that
many of the countries have also opened
comma special stock market for example
in Tokyo you see just act right in Korea
you see call stack and these are like
pretty like low volume market so in
cause drag most probably if you have a
company close to a million dollar in
revenue you can actually go IPO so you
need to know the techniques and that's
what we become very valuable because we
have worked with most of the markets and
we can actually take a company from
Myanmar and actually I pewitt in Korea
and and we can help with that that's
what we are doing that's what the job of
a VC is I guess right so let me ask
about the other end of the spectrum what
about sourcing deals you mentioned I can
imagine that tech in Asia is really
useful you know to get the kind of
information they're bringing in you
mentioned universities can you say a
little bit more about them as kind of
deal sources yes so recently we're
seeing a lot of lot of great deals from
universities on in US for example your
University startx and bases are the two
big sources for us that we do not miss
any of these events that you guys do we
also have like in campus we also get it
from the old entrepreneurs for example
Julia who I was talking about right she
has a lot of friends from Stanford sure
every now and then we'll throw a company
at us and all the companies will throw
at us
good quality companies are not any you
know random companies that she is
running across so we are getting a lot
of startups also from the incubators for
example Y Combinator is a biggest source
of our of our deal sourcing mechanism we
also get companies from TechStars which
is actually the second largest incubator
in the world right now located in
Colorado in foreign countries we get a
lot of sources from the incubators and
also from friends and ecosystem players
for example i have my friend cutters on
here a lot of deals we get from daiwa
securities which is a like an
underwriter for for for japan right to
get a lot of juice from him so like
ecosystem player it can be the
Securities companies it can be the
auditors likes the deloitte is a big
source for our deal sourcing so you get
a lot of deals from Deloitte we also get
a lot of deal sources from the stock
exchanges themselves because they can
actually point you out to the great
companies that have a good IPO potential
so we get from everyone universities are
playing a major role nowadays especially
in Japan we are actually getting some
companies which are just amazing I mean
the quality of the technology and and
the entrepreneurs around it that they
have been able to put together so you
know in diversity is definitely becomes
a big source I hope that the other
universities in the world they also have
a statics and basis like you but they do
not so I mean they're lacking some some
basic resources there but we are trying
to get it from the ecosystem from the
students from the teachers but this Ilya
is a labor-intensive approach to
investing I think in terms of listening
to what you're doing and how much you
are involved in helping the company's
find partners and develop strategies
that is more than most of the VC
companies that I've heard I do not sleep
I tell you so I am I am working
delivered seven and so is my team I have
a team of great young entrepreneurs who
are actually they work very hard we have
I told you from a regular VC we have lot
more many people with 53 people around
the world I have representation from
different countries in my team I have a
hair yokomo broader distant and show
your face to everyone so she actually
came all the way from Japan
to help for help us i also have john
over there john actually also
understands cody and she actually helps
with our korean market so we also have
team all over asia we have about six
people in Korea bunch of people in Japan
or six people in Indonesia three people
in Bangladesh and you know all around
the world so we actually in 10
intentionally try to hire a lot of young
people and the reason is being that
people really work hard and they do not
they are just thinking ahead of them I
mean they're not seeing like when I have
to go back so they're really working
hard and making it happen and we're a
team together and that's where we are
trying to make a difference do you see a
rise in sort of the quality of
entrepreneurship across Asia not only
the you know the market potential and
the great ideas and the great investment
potential certainly there's been a lot
of Education about entrepreneurship
there's been a lot of discussion about
entrepreneurship in different Asian
countries some of which have better
reputations for being entrepreneurial
than others but are you seeing
differences over the last few years I
think in the last two years I've seen a
huge wave of innovation and
entrepreneurship in Asia especially
starting from countries like Korea the
government is extremely active the
government is actually investing in all
Silicon Valley pc farms so that they can
invest back into skolian stirrups a lot
of wave from Japan Japanese large
corporations are moving they are trying
to do something for their own business
we are seeing a lot of big wave in
countries like Singapore Singapore has
always been very active in matching
funding and and doing things like that
so we are seeing a huge wave but it
still as was mentioned in dr. dash are a
lot of entrepreneurs one commonality we
are seeing across all these countries
most of them are you as graduates and
that sometimes something that relaxes me
a little bit but at the same time I
think that when they will be influencing
others the local ones and grow more
local entrepreneurs I think we need to
wait for that day I have not seen that
happening in a big way today but that is
pretty exciting are there other
questions
do you see a competition from local DC's
you know their periods of course we
don't like in Korea there's so many
marketing entrepreneurs and you said
government is gonna happen so I just
wondering you know how this decision so
good question that how much of local
competition that we're seeing and v's vc
i would say that most of the local feces
have been pretty cooperative rather than
competing they are also seeing us as a
partner and i have seen that across
japan I've seen that a lot in Korea the
Korean pieces have been very friendly
and they like the fact that we are there
to help startups in their country rather
than you know we have we are there to
take over there mill so people are
seeing it in a different way and I'm see
I'm sure that it has a lot to do it for
example Korean education system most
probably they are pretty much open to
the American investors that are going
from Silicon Valley it was surprised to
know that we are not that big of a farm
from Silicon Valley we are not know
sequoia or no kleiner perkins but one of
the things that have given us a amazing
advantage that we are from Silicon
Valley thank god this place was there i
mean i have got into so many great deals
around the world because i had only one
quality I was prom Silicon Valley guys
this is amazing take advantage of this
and I'm taking advantage of this
everywhere I go before I say that my
name is honest whose man i say that i am
from Silicon Valley that gives you the
advantage so what do you exactly provide
to the you know the corporate investors
because you essentially urz provide
what's are you guys so the VCS are to
provide zip and a capital gain but not
the information but what do you exactly
alike so that I let me take a little bit
of time to explain that that what is
this is next month right we make capital
gain so what is the benefit of the big
corporations investing in us and I will
explain that so as the new generation vc
by the way guys I mean to
you heard about finals for the first
time in your life it is not the last
time I can tell you I have a challenge
in the last four years we have grown
from a zero dollar fun to a 1.5 billion
dollar company today and in the last
four years I mean we are growing
exponentially and we want to become the
venture capital Google of venture
capital industry because you want to
grow very fast and you would hear
Phoenix more and more and maybe not much
more than you want to hear from now on
what we have done we have disrupted the
venture capital model itself because of
the need of the large corporations so
large corporations they do not need
financial return they tell me that I
give you one dollar if you can give my
one double back after 10 years I am
happy with that I do not need one point
one dollar ten cents back what I need in
these 10 years of commitment I want you
to give me information about top
technologies top trends so what we did
we broke the traditional VC model today
we actually generate these thick of a
report every single month for our
investors and in that report we write
down the top deals that we see in a
month and we summarize them together and
that's why we have so many people
actually working on the due diligence of
these companies what we do we disclose
this information to them and this is
something that is already publicly
available but we put it together based
on our expertise and knowledge we put it
together we'll give it to their hands
they see this magazine this thick
magazine every month they flip through
it and this alike I like this company I
like this company I am a automotive
maker maybe this company can give me a
better windshield and I should come
contact the sister ups what we do we
have business development people within
our forum they actually take this
japanese investor and contact this
startup and put them together now they
have business relationship we have also
seen margarine acquisition win-win for
both side the startup is also very happy
that Phoenix help bridge my relationship
with a in with any they're like a big
manufacturer from Japan or Korea or from
Singapore right both sides are happy so
that's what we are doing and we have
seen tremendous success in the last two
years we have been able to put together
a lot of relationships together we're a
big corporation from Japan or Korea or
Singapore came in and actually they
could partner with a start-up from new
york and both sides are very happy and
phoenix was the bridge because we had
access to both side and both side
trusted us so we could put it together
now on the financial return side guys if
we do not make financial return I cannot
keep it speaking I have to die okay so
ferox today and this is also another
thing that I can be proud up on the
fourth year our irr is seventy-eight
percent there's something that no one
can match and how we do that you see the
passion energy I have every single
member of panax are simply as passionate
and energized as I am and that's what we
are making a difference and we'll keep
making the difference well one more
question just until you see there are
stars from the smaller say Asian
countries how do we how did it go across
the different cultures in different
countries if they want to expand your
boring life for member companies okay so
how do they spend in other countries
right here because in each Asian
countries they have many different
cultures and usage patterns and so on
yeah so I think you're the short answer
is they need to most probably get
invested by global player so that the
investor can help them spread out even
the start I am trying to say so if your
company is located in Thailand for
example most probably should get
invested by a Singaporean investor
because they are kind of like in the
center of Asia right so they can
actually help you spread out and they
have enough connections most probably to
hook you up with the right player so
that you can from a company can become a
Vietnam accompany you can become a
Filipino company and then you can become
to a Singaporean company as well right
so when you are growing I mean have a
few things that you need to maintain
register your company in a location that
everybody likes right so most of my
asian investment outside of japan most
of my investment are registered in sync
for even the to Bangladesh company that
I invested guys as an investor I cannot
risk your money because you gave me the
money because you trust me i made sure i
made them register in United States or
Singapore before I made an investment
because I want to make sure my LPS are
protected my investors are protected so
we did the due diligence it took us six
long months to bring the Yahoo of
Bangladesh to reregister them from
Bangladesh to Delaware and only then we
invested that was our investment
condition that we have to be registered
in the US where the Singapore actually
provides the best asset in general in
addition to the risk of handling
favorite law so it's actually if you can
you're actually better off and Singapore
that you are I'll teach us your company
and it'll be yours company owned by that
company single totally ugly I cannot pay
you know I totally agree to you but at
the same time because of our manpower
mainly in u.s. it is easy for us to
handle a lot of things on the US side
rather than other Singapore side yes
you